Yannick Morez élue à
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins annonce sa
démission au préfet j'ai pris cette
décision pour des raisons personnelles
notamment suite à l'incendie criminel
perpétré à mon domicile une maison et
des véhicules incendiés c'était le 22
mars dernier le domicile de Yannick
Morez était visé par une attaque depuis
la volonté de l'État de construire un
centre d'accueil pour migrants dans
cette école les manifestations les
menaces se sont multipliées contre lui
c'est la question de la protection de
nos élus c'est la question aussi de
l'habitude qui a été prise cette forme
de violence ces insultes ses menaces on
va continuer à renforcer notre action
pour intervenir plus tôt pour pouvoir
soutenir les mers pour repérer leurs
difficultés et mieux les accompagner il
est temps de se lever de se lever en
l'honneur de Yannick borez de se lever
pour le droit et de mettre sélection
en Europe selon l'Association des maires
de France au moins 1500 élus municipaux
ont été victimes d'agression l'an
dernier des tensions qui contribuent à
un autre phénomène inquiétant les
démissions d'élus il serait plus de 4700
à avoir démissionné depuis 2020 et un
élu qui démissionne dans ses conditions
c'est naturellement une tâche dans notre
République donc nous devons prendre en
compte ce message hier soir l'affaire a
pris une tournure politique la majorité
des députés s'est levé pour rendre
hommage à Yannick Morez les députés du
rassemblement national sont eux restés
assis victime lui de ce qu'il qualifie
être un terrorisme d'extrême droite et
donc des événements de cette nature
nous interpellent pas de boulot
[Applaudissements]
et puis Marine Le Pen également a réagi
en décembre dit-elle elle avait alerté
sur la montée des violences de la part
de groupuscules extrémisme de tout bord
politique depuis aucune mesure a été
prise aucune action a été menée je le
précise évidemment toute violence
politique et sur le principe absolument
insupportable d'où qu'elle vienne cette
absencement
évident maintenant je vous le dis il y a
une unanimité heureuse et légitime de la
classe politique à condamné ce qui s'est
passé et donc oui nous avons plus des
industrialisés que les autres ce qui
nous place dans une situation d'impasse
d'abord parce que ça veut dire que on
crée des dépendances quand on des
industrialise qu'on le veuille ou non et
on l'a vécu parfois plus que d'autres
dans la période covid ou ailleurs ça
m'ont fermé des centres industriels nous
pensons nous allons être uniquement un
pays tertiaire mais ça c'est Monsieur
Macron et les gouvernements auxquels il
a participé les gens aujourd'hui qui
participent à des gouvernements avec lui
qui l'ont fait ne vont pas répliquer les
erreurs que nous avons faites sur par
exemple le photovoltaïque on a déployé
massivement photovoltaïque en Europe et
on a au même moment massivement détruit
notre industrie photovoltaïque et donc
on a construit une dépendance à l'égard
de la Chine et on a fait réussir
l'industrie chinoise je ne veux pas
qu'on le réplique sur en particulier les
questions de la batterie désormais on va
dire si vous voulez avoir le bonus il
faut que le véhicule réponde à
l'exigence des États-Unis désormais
c'est bien ça on va enfin défendre nos
intérêts comme les américains comme les
Chinois président de la République
applique une technique bien connue celle
de Nicolas Sarkozy une annonce par jour
un et son but et en particulier de
fermer la séquence retraite en montrant
que on est passé à autre chose on peut
penser par exemple au Dacia spring qui
certes aujourd'hui soupe pavillon
tricolore son produites quasi
exclusivement en Chine ce qui pourrait
les pénaliser par rapport au marché
domestique il y avait un petit
pharmacien de Nancy s'appelait mille
Coué la méthode Coué
quel est l'objectif il est politique de
changer la conversation accrochez-vous
la scène se déroule au Brésil et vous
plonge au une course poursuite non vous
n'êtes pas dans Fast and Furious mais
dans le vécu d'un policier de Sao Paulo
qui pourchasse un couple en moto à sans
domicile fixe à sauver la vie d'un
nourrisson cela s'est passé aux
États-Unis le premier mai dernier alors
qu'il sortait d'un entretien d'embauche
dans un restaurant en Californie Loma a
perçu cette poussette qui a échappé à la
vigilance de sa mère et il est parvenu à
empêcher que le bébé ne soit violemment
percuté sur une route très fréquentée le
suspense est au rendez-vous pendant plus
de 5 minutes de caméra embarquée et au
bout de 8 km la chute de l'histoire vous
êtes offerte par les fuyards qui
finiront interpeller et à pied
[Musique]